dylan's in tucson arizona hi dylan how
are you
hey dave and dr d thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
uh so my my fiance and i are both 24
years old
i'm on baby step four um and she's
currently on baby step two
um she has about 28 000 in debt
um we're getting married at the end of
april uh we have enough cash to cover
the wedding
um and then i'll even have a little bit
left over
um to throw on her dead after the
wedding um some of that's my
current emergency fund great plan
yeah and then after uh after the wedding
after we got off the debt
uh we plan on starting step 3d saving up
for a house
so my question is um in the meantime
should i continue investing my 15
from now up until the wedding at which
point i would pause that so we can pay
down debt
or should i pause it now um and then
just pile up as much cash
as i can right now to fill up the debt
uh after the wedding
man you are on fire your your critical
thinking skills are incredible those
were questions i was not asking at age
24. god
believe man good for you dylan
i don't even no i don't even i'm not
going there
[Laughter]
man seriously that's awesome no i would
pause and pile up cash
until you've got enough cash to cover
the wedding
heard that after the wedding uh baby
step three of an emergency fund and torn
into 3b pretty hard so
yeah i'd be doing nothing on retirement
right now you need a bigger
pile of cash as much as you can get
together dude and you are
really got this thing dialed in i'm so
proud of you very well done
is she on board with you on all this
uh she is she's not um you know i'm the
nerd she's the free spirit
um and i'm obviously a way bigger fan of
you guys than she is at the moment
um but she's on board we're actually
getting ready to take uh sbu at our
church
um at the beginning of next month wow
great pre-marriage counseling
yeah absolutely so we're just kind of in
the planning stages right now
um working on getting on the same page
and all that
yeah well done that's outstanding
congratulations dylan so where did you
learn how to do all this
um well you know you uh the dave ramsey
name has obviously
always been well known to me um around
the church um
you know my church always had fbu
classes and
all the you know my parents and all the
other grown-ups would always take it
um so i always knew about you once i
graduated college
uh almost two years ago and
you know was getting ready to start my
big boy job
that's when i kind of really started
listening to you and getting into it
just because the
amount of money i was going to be making
was honestly intimidating
um and you know i was kind of
scared of having all that money and not
really having a plan for it so
that's cool so basically you were you're
a financial piece baby
and so when you start having some money
you said i got to do this the grown-up
way i'm going gonna dive in learn how to
do it
very cool man exactly very cool i love
it well done dylan
well done that's generational stuff
right there man that's funny
that's a legacy turnover that's right
that's fun i like the second gen
third gen is even better that's cool
second gender kids
third gen's grandkids and knowing how
great grandkids are going to be out have
been nicer to their parents